[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club round 2 of the
Spring Classic here in st. Louis
the Masters section was high quality
chess to the tune of nothing but draws
grandmaster alexander owner shook
remains at the top of the leader board
along with grandmaster jeffrey zhang the
challengers section had three decisive
victories all for white grandmaster
action Chandra's campaign is still
perfect as his two dangerous past ponds
were too much for national master Erin
Griffin ski the feeling out period is
coming to an end
coverage of round 3 starts now
with over $30,000 in pride on the line
20 international chess professionals
converged in st. Louis for the 2018
spring chess classic
[Music]
hello chess fans and welcome back to st.
Louis for day three round three of the
2018 spring chess classic it's the
strongest seasonal event ever here at
the club my name is Ben Simon and I've
had a namer
and we are the two most fashionably
coordinated men in chess at least for
today oh yeah definitely and easily
isn't that a prize for the best fashion
the chess commentators I don't know is
there right now maybe not not so much
but we are in the midst of this spring
chess classic with 210 player
round-robin events but let's take a look
first at what happened last night
because we've already had two rounds
last night round two in our masters
division it was all draws oh yeah I mean
I mean it's a draw fest well you know
top level chess that's what we're
talking about now let's take a look at
the standings nothing has changed here
but there is an interesting aspect you
pointed out vitally yeah so why do we
see so many drawers besides the fact
that they're playing so well if you can
see that we have the top chest at the
top seed Alexandre on issue with the
rating of 2681 and we have the bottom
seat seed Romain and award with 26 13
which makes the the margin of the rating
just about 70 points so this is why it's
going to be a such a closed fight these
PJ ratings are a measurement of playing
strengths in classical events this is a
classical event so yeah it's logical to
think these scores are going to be in
line with what those ratings are and
roughly they are everyone is really
close together it's still anyone's chess
tournament but we do have a challengers
division here Group B let's take a look
at what happened last night here at the
Chess Club as we were going off the air
we had a few the size of results
yesterday under yegorovich one with
white the white pieces Ajax team bhulok
victor McAuliffe ski beat with the white
pieces medication that's just before we
left the game was still going on but
did as called the points jacob Morandi
and played a shock upon drew the game I
wonder Liang and Alexander fear also
drew the game and action Chandra still
on the winning streak beating Aaron
grabbin ski indeed I mean we're only two
games in but the winning streak is
enough to put AK shot clear at the top
it's the standings will show
Akshay Chandra st. Louis's own with two
points a big ol zero in the lost column
and everybody else is just trying to
play catch-up here yeah okay
so that brings us to today we have games
that have started just a few hours ago
remember each day at 1 p.m. the games
start but now we are going to catch you
up with what's going on
let's take a look at the games in Group
A the pairings that are happening right
now at us chest champs calm yeah so
let's see so Sam chenkin with the white
pieces is playing against Dario spirits
Romain Edward is playing against a
version of Kobe on Alex and Ashok vs.
Lazaro bruise on Yara Sharapova's plane
against Surya Ganguly in Jeffrey Zhang
with the white pieces playing against
Alex a path of a our game of the day the
one that will most be likely to look at
in Group A Alexander ona shook and
Lazaro Brazil yeah we child they're
probably the top seeds in their ratings
so that's gonna be pretty exciting to
watch if let's say owner sugar wins this
he might be running away with this a
little bit early on right so this is an
important game and now the pairings for
Group B this is also happening right now
a u.s. chess champs calm we have our
grab in ski playing white against Andre
Gaurav it's Alexander fear versus action
Chandra prepared a Chicano Park versus a
wonder Liang Malika Cheon versus JJ
Morandi and ejected stain blocker versus
victim Michalowski and before we take a
look at the game of the day in this
division I want to give everybody a
heads up we've been informed from the
tournament hall that there is a dgt
error and if you're watching on us chess
champs you've probably already figured
that out those last
we're games their fear Chandra can't pan
land
Kashian Murali Morandi Stamboul e AK and
mikhalev ski all of those games have
lost their transmission now any game any
moves that you do see come through will
be manually input by our wonderful
international arbiter Mike comer but I
think he is maybe lost the good fight
because that is for games to follow it
is quite a bit we do have garb in ski
angora vet still being relayed so we'll
do our best to bring this to you now
with all that being said our game of the
day still it's not changing the one to
watch alexander fear and akshat chandra
and hopefully we can get one of these
players in here to tell us what exactly
happened in their game if it ends and we
still don't know what happened ourselves
to be quite frank no surprises yes let's
take a look at our tournament format
it's pretty easy to understand we have
210 player round robin events all play
all nine rounds we're in the third round
today the time control is 90 minutes for
the first 40 moves and then 30 minutes
bonus after 40 moves on both clocks
there is a 30 second increment from move
number one and there is a 30 move draw
rule in effect so what that means is
neither player can offer or accept a
draw until after black has played and
thus both players have played their 30th
move and this is to encourage fighting
chance yes exactly I've done five let's
see some blood spills yes and that's
what we're here for
let's take a look at the schedule round
three is going on right now each day at
1 p.m. central with the games will begin
here in st. Louis and we're on the air
with you every day at 3:30 p.m. now
you'll notice the last two days Tuesday
and Wednesday the games will begin two
hours earlier which means we'll be on
the air two hours earlier at 1:30 p.m.
the closing ceremony unfortunately is
not televised oh that's gonna be a good
one right yeah and by the way on the
weekend we have a time change yes are we
going to be sleeping less or more less
I'm sorry
obviously being less that we are going
into daylight saving time so we'll
remind you as we get closer to that also
now the players actually were informed
by Mike comer and 20 rich I believe
before the event we are gonna be having
daylight saving time going into Sunday
morning so you know set your clocks and
immediately everyone was like hold on
hold on what's going on here because not
all these players know about daylight
saving time here in the US so right I
guess the rent right it's different from
other other countries right so and what
0 so if they if they miss it by an hour
they might profit the game they will
forfeit the game the players actually
have up to 30 minutes to make it to the
tournament hall or else the game is
forfeit if they miss if they arrive late
to the round they can still play they're
just gonna be losing time on the clock
but 30 minutes it's over so you can't do
that
there was actually a tournament here a
few months ago one of these big
tournaments I believe that was a classic
and and one of the players was starting
up the stairs because it was like 29
minutes it was almost like a tragedy oh
right yeah do you not want to miss that
out may disqualify you from prizes I'm
not sure mm-hmm
speaking of prizes let's take a look at
those group a has a $22,000 prize fund
Italian yeah the first place is going to
take out at a hefty $6,000 second-place
four thousand dollars and the third
place is going to take three thousand
dollars and basically all the all the
places to get get something a thousand
dollars even for the last price and that
includes Group B as well with the 14
thousand dollar prize fund here's how it
all breaks down right the top of the top
player player is gonna get $4,000 and
then at the second and the third place
is gonna get 2500 and $2,000 and even
the last place is gonna walk away the
$500 now I have to mention you been when
I was playing myself in my youth well I
was the one who had to pay the entry fee
I had to pay for the flights and hotels
and everything so the conditions that
the players are getting here are just
are just amazing right I mean you you
get a prize anyway you get might get a
hotel in there in a flight it's just a
win-win situation so
that's that's a great there's really
nothing that is playing chess in st.
Louis and remember like the Grantchester
events we have Magnus Carlsen and all of
the so-called super grandmasters because
there's no title above Grand Master and
they're coming to town and they're
really given the red carpet treatment
and it's not too different from these
guys and these are the 2600 grandmasters
often those opportunities don't exist
for the grand chests or like circuits
for these guys so this is a big deal
yeah yeah and they we always welcome
some some new players if anybody wants
to participate and you can always send
us an email at info at the st. Louis
chess club org yeah that's not if you
want do you want to play one of those
tournaments and we'd be remiss if we
didn't wish everybody out there watching
on us chess job champs calm a happy
International Women's Day March 8th
vitality started all the way back in
1917 in Russia
Oh Russian by the way we have lots of
Russian viewers supposed of Yahoo FC
attention Swiss Miss boys mom Martha
what he said yes okay so we thought all
that said and done let's take a look at
what is happening so far let's get into
the action alrighty so let's start with
our games of the day the one which we
have is group a on knee shook versus
bruise on and that's gonna be a close
fight so as of right now it looks like
White has some edge because of the
activity of his pieces now if you see
the pawns here on e3 and E - that might
be concerning for for white but may
probably in the long term not right now
so right now
black in this last move played this move
rope to a7 hmm that's a that's a very
looking very strange-looking move right
it doesn't look like a movie you want to
play exactly I mean usually the rooks
are just gonna what just wants to come
to d8 well the problem is is that to get
this route to d8 he needs to move the
bishop well how do we get the bishop out
if we play Bishop d7 for example then
we are going to hang we might have hang
upon here on v7 not immediately but
that's gonna become much much weaker and
so and eventually by the way and if
black tries to play beef I well he's
just going to hang the rook so that rook
on the a8 really wanted to go out so
bruise on I had to play the rook a seven
with the idea I think to play to play
the b5 move with a pawn and then
swinging his route to d7 or maybe or
maybe c7 so very very interesting that
variation yeah so as I said looks like
white is slightly better he has more
chances maybe if white wants to stop
platform from pushing his pawn to to b5
he might play something like pawn to a4
yeah so I think that that white is
pretty good in here let's try to play a
four here and yeah I actually prefer
white a little bit this rook on f4 is
probably going to swing to d4 white has
the control over the over the D file
looks looks pretty good pretty good for
white we will see how how bruised on I
needs to find how to equalize it's not
so easy so we are going to get back to
this game let's see what other games do
we have here it's notable to say here
that only shook and bruised own are two
of the elder statesmen in this group
along with Ganguly burrs own is 35 and
own Ashok the the chess veteran himself
is playing so many championships is 42
so in chess ears 42 is that is that
enough to be the oldest well in this
field it is yeah yeah and by the way on
this chick also has another job he is
coaching at chess team at Texas tax oh
yeah
so he's a coach any professional chess
player that's that's quite impressive
yes you know I'm for example for me I'm
just I'm just coaching professional and
they take so much time so doing both is
together is pretty impressive it's quite
a balancing act for sure okay so let's
see what else do we have here let's look
at Jeffrey Zhang and Alexandra epitope
at their game okay well that is also
looking pretty interesting what do we
have here so why it is a pawn up on e4
and I like that also Black has those two
double pawns on g4 and g6 right now it's
white to move and obviously his roof is
attacked on d4
I suspect that white is deciding where
to move his rook there are some
interesting ideas he might move the rope
to c4 to attack this pawn on c5 which is
going to be very difficult for black to
the Fed actually because it doesn't have
b6 knight Knight would just take the
pawn b6 on the other hand maybe he wants
to play rude III just to move the rock
backwards or maybe Rudy to just in just
to make sure to defend this h2 pawn
because I think that blacks ideas might
be to play rook h8 and attack this pawn
on h2 yeah lots of ideas I I really like
White's 91 d5 really lots of lots of
squares to go to you can go to F 4 C 7 e
7
b6 you can you can both attack and
defend at the same time and that's
that's what really we like about our
pieces in chess I mean if they can
attack and defend multitask retasking so
yeah I really like White's position I'm
not sure if Jeff is going to choose
oopsie 42 is that what you would call an
octopus night kind of yes but an octopus
night is mostly when he like
acts many pieces okay but yes it's it's
like a mega fork in a it's not tools but
yeah this this one also looks like an
octopus - that's true yeah so yeah maybe
we should change the name maybe we
should change it is from a knife take
the piece to an octopus a new piece
nitrogen hey we've got we've got the
Sarah one pieces let's make it an
octopus yeah exactly
now let's look at some other games so
yeah so this this one is I think the
Jeffrey's in the driver seats so far
let's see
Yellowstone general booth against so
yeah Ganguli as we said so shareable he
lost his first game that he drew his
second game and I would really like to
see if he can come back and strike back
so let's see what's going on here so it
looks like white is leaving alright so
white has a rope for a bishop and a pawn
so technically white is material leading
the question is what is going on here
right how do we evaluate the skiing on
c7 in the screen on a six I mean
probably the king one c7 looks a bit
weak but again white is lacking the dark
squared bishop so there isn't Donald and
he checks from this diagonal on the king
and that's a value of the screen a six I
mean the Queen ASIS
it looks like it's behind enemy lines
right it's kind of there are lots of
threats in there but right now what is
she doing there she feels very lonely
along the Queen I would assume white
will try to support the Queen with some
pieces or maybe we can see some
exchanges let's make you move can i play
maybe
maybe I can try to play a four here with
white sorry to interrupt Batali we have
two results in first of all in Group A
Sam Shanklin and Darius spirits have
drawn their game in Group B one of our
blackout games that we're having the
relay issues with has ended but I don't
know the result
Melik Kashian and a lemur on D is over
so we'll try to figure out the result of
that game I like some surprises here
that's what you're gonna get you're
gonna get a surprise so that means yes
Sam chenkin just drew which means that
so far he's he has three draws this is a
draw master so far probably some of some
other players from that field also made
a few draws but we had so far everything
is JA but yeah going back to this
position now I realize that maybe if Y
plays a four black might have this very
sneaky tactic Bishop to c7
and the Queen has to go to a eight and
now Bishop to be seven the Queen has
nowhere to go because the Queen is
basically trapped she is trapped yeah
yeah
now hold on for that position does rook
takes f7 work oh yes and yeah it's yeah
we can save the queen
yes yeah that's that's correct and then
the blinkin can probably go out but in
this case probably even rook f1 is
coming and I suspect that will not be
such it's so good for white so a for a
probably not a good idea
yeah I don't know I mean maybe you can
try to play something like Bishop to f5
to try to exchange this bishop because
that's eventually how is going to defend
against against this threat so yeah if
Italia I've just been told that they're
like Kakashi has won the game
Oh wonderful talking to him in a very
very short time excellent yes all right
it's so exciting exciting things we
haven't discussed with medic haven't
seen him on the show yet so we will see
it was his first win I think right and
especially coming back from yesterday
right yesterday he lost to Michael F
Sookie correct yeah so nice comeback yes
very nice comeback okay so okay so in
the interim what else do we have going
well what errand grab in ski can he come
back from his loss from yesterday let's
see he is that's in a big group and he's
playing against Andre Gaurav it's so on
till one yesterday
we'll see if they have this momentum
let's see so so far aaron has well his
time advantage when unfortunately fused
look at white pieces they kind of
cramped the roofs on e3 and f1
definitely black has space advantage I
mean look at those beautiful pawns on c5
defy before I mean what else can I ask
that's that's way I mean this night on
d3 tough it's a tough position for for
Aaron he's an underdog but we can keep
cheering for him so yeah I don't know I
it's hard to how to try to predict what
he's going to do basically now black is
attacking the b2 pawn and the f2 pawn
with a knight
that's another octopus here over there
yes and yeah I mean white needs to
decide do I defend the f2 pawn or the
beetle well I think that probably f2 is
going to be more precise because
obviously if white moves the pawn this
one why black is going to form the king
and the Queen and white we have to
sacrifice this rope and this is looking
pretty bad for white so probably Aaron
is is deciding what what do i do do I
just do I just defend this pawn after
with Queen to e2
if you place Queenie - I wonder maybe
black it as something like group to eg
to or maybe just Knight to f4 looking
pretty dangerous for for Aaron so yeah
so I I cannot see a way for Aaron to to
make a move which will defend all of his
all of his pieces it's gonna be there's
gonna be a tough tough fight for him hmm
probably maybe he's trying to figure out
if he is if he wants to sacrifice the
rook for the night
let's see if we have some some other
moves coming in
yeah it's going to be definitely
definitely a tough fight for him
interesting
all right so we are going to be back to
that fight but right now we have an
exciting guest and I'll show and melly
coach Ian welcome thank you
congratulations on you win yeah it's a
you by the way you finished on move
number forty so yeah I'd say is simply
waiting for a move forty that's kind of
yeah it didn't want to play another
another hour right all right so um so
let's let's look at you at your game so
they're so pretty nice I come back by
the way after yesterday Oh yesterday
what upset yesterday was actually quite
good game that was winning at some point
right right you had this move a quintic
see one on top of this I could play b5
and then nail the King and it was pretty
much meaning I'm not sure what's
happened to me I mean I saw the B flat
move I saw how I'm winning the game but
I thought the way how I play this type
of forcing win right
and I just miscalculated something and
then I saw I could have a draw but I
thought no I need to play for win so
it's my fault yeah pretty much yeah
what's the time pressure right right
that's why today I figured I said to
myself I'll be playing faster no more
time scramble you know control the pace
stay happy stay positive
that's hope a bell for yourself yes
there was terrible day for me on top of
losing the game to Michalowski I tried
to play protest League
yeah and I was completely down I lost
you know yesterday in st. Louis where
though this rain and snow
and today you could go out we have all
the Sun and the beautiful weather so
yeah maybe the mood changes you know
that's the life
yeah I'm day bad good yeah of course
nice comeback so let's go over your game
today so let's I knew my point of a play
fresh I sort of had that the same Felix
because he's playing multiple openings
but since I the first round
I didn't play well against sure
Shambu lack mm-hmm some stimulus I'm
sorry stammer like so I thought since
he's been playing this line before so he
might be repeating the same thing mm-hmm
and obviously I prepared something you
okay
and so he always played this night of 6
or even cause at the time when he plays
French yes he's mostly chosen to play
this some more than another 6 yeah yeah
so this is Bishop g5 that the way how I
was playing Bishop to seven takes takes
and I assumed by the way that you guys
got the parents even before
yeah the tournament so you started to be
paying like a weeks before problem it is
but I mean I get prepared weeks before
as according you against few players
mm-hmm
not against that particular person
because I had no time when I preparing
against him I thought he's going to be
playing if I mm-hmm that's what he's
like main choice hmm so that's what I
was expecting but I mean the French was
my sort of second time second rice good
guess
yeah sometimes it's a bet right right
yeah
c4 this is like a very rare move so do
they usually take you with the pollen
just six books passable as possible
there's two different lines we should
this is one line G of his next line it's
it sounds like if you if he takes with a
pawn he just wants more aggressive play
like I don't want to draw he's a player
that's why I thought that mean the
Acacia clearly they would the whole game
he was trying to be aggressive and I was
trying to calm him down
mm okay very nice very nice you're kind
of dodging dodging and you see for this
is a rare move
she was very rare move not too many
games in database but I analyzed
something and I came to conclusion quite
as in a try mm-hmm so b6 one of the
tries yeah we should be the design to
kind of prevent to be sure b7 okay so it
should be seven then yeah yeah what's
family expecting like f5 f5 year not c3
we should have six under stuff
three maybe bishop of framelits show
something and then see 692 yeah and then
would you consider still casting short
or would you a little question so you
know I have no answer to it perhaps
perhaps that gets a king-sized yeah okay
yeah don't do that scale of three I feel
secure
uh-huh yeah I feel secure yeah I mean
they control the center yeah makes sense
and the worry is he gonna go I mean he
can't castle sure yeah because you know
whenever you take a commitment by that
you get pause structure as he has done
so you've gotta have some other benefits
and as I said this is quite nice setup
because he needs to prove it
right what he wants to do I mean my
phone is easy I'm going to castle I'm
going to consult my physician move Mike
we move my rooks the right moment
breakthrough in the center right I mean
yeah yeah those beautiful I think that
probably his only chance would be
somehow to transposed to an end game
with two bishops yeah yeah obviously
wouldn't one right something like that
yeah but I mean actually I don't know in
the game he never could
so let's see how what happens so so you
paid ninety six and seven yeah that's
another really you know communing move
because he made message six it's quite
you know attractive to John find that
tech my Paul Andrew g8 yeah yeah yeah we
should be something that's it three and
og8 I mean honestly I knew it he's gonna
play UGA at the game time yeah you know
because very fancy like if you play
castle then that 64 stuff mm-hmm
so so here's ah ha so here yeah so if
you castles here they just show this
then night things d4 Ryan yep well then
he just takes everything right oh yeah
this is sweeping everything yeah after
you
yeah okay yeah I mean I knew he's gonna
try something like that but I think I'm
read briefly top the stuff of three
minutes
looks like he simply missed night I mean
d5 move here mmm-hmm nice nice counter
punch
yeah you missed that move and then it
looks like he has to take I'm not sure I
mean but it looks like a drink right
yeah and that's a CD he has to go that
before
and now Cooney for Chuck search you know
now if I would be him
right right I would have play 27 I would
say yeah whatever
kinga faith mine let's die but die for
something at least you know yeah yeah I
mean all-in right
oh yeah well because he's really like
compromising his position so I thought
he must play King f8 and they tried to
pick up my d5 pawn he actually I was
going to play Castle kingside mm-hmm
it's what I thought Castle kingside 95
Lodi one okay d1 and then let's say c6
take on d5 25 and that d4 nice block
either yeah something like that I was I
was considering to play maybe I should
plan a clinic for first make sure my
queen is like you know a switch to the
king side and it seems like you got a
lot of compensation all for sure all for
sure yeah especially with the time
pressure coming in right this is
pleasant for white right yeah okay yeah
so on Queen 1/4 I said he played Queen
d7
yeah but the Queen d7 does - basically
it's like a straight to the endgame just
I don't know I think it's a simple
better for me though right yeah I was
surprised honestly maybe maybe forgot
about Bishop b5 and he just saw he saw
it he he responded it really quickly c6
he saw him but the fee this is like
super by me I need to check with
computer my thing that looks like it DC
really forcing me shoves his six yeah a
few bishops a six question six question
six 96 and now it's very important move
it's 95
yeah I mean again he had a Felix he
didn't play like he didn't defend
properly this is not so bad right
this is must be defendable right right I
mean he's I mean you upon this hanging
on g2 and so the D begins to play like
here like maybe Bishop da
and I thought that's the only move right
I owe over the other bit of the few
times I don't like moves backwards so
why why can't they play like just like
rook c8 or something
well the thing is like you've mentioned
early on I mean I like to keep my bishop
in the game typically in the end games
like a bishop supposed to be better than
night so you take only seven well I
would I would for sure I won't take only
seven a similar endgame but I mean maybe
you're right maybe it'll say it was
better worship for sure because let's
say at least there is some headache
reflux it to right some of you think
yeah but the mini game let's say I take
when he's seventh what are gonna do
okay I'm gonna be brave and I think for
the King no I always move forward not
necessary should be done yeah okay
that's fine ninety seven seven castle
and oxygen
yeah I thought about its line but I mean
I don't know the question is can you
handle it
can you handle this poem can i play it
something like gonna be like you said
brave and do something like I don't know
look if you want to yeah something like
I don't maybe I'm okay c1 maybe like d4
yeah okay maybe I have to move my king
yeah it's it's pretty complicated but
look see so I mean what better Brad does
that's true
yeah you know better yeah so maybe
that's why he wanted to avoid those
complications yeah yeah but maybe right
I mean that's what may be the most event
the best chance anyway because there was
our hip but it was so passive wish of
the AIDS you know he production we cast
a queen right yeah believe he precursor
of Queen so often 95 year he passes but
now the difference is the rukon da does
have access to jump on the two so I can
take take and Kessel here another chance
I thought in the only mo here who
decreed
he got a create complication but now we
have a backbone structure you have to do
something because some activities
something need to compensate your poor
structure
and he didn't feel the urgency he just
thought this is where he can handle it
but he played this impulsive 95 yeah so
what is what is your pen do you want to
exchange the ropes very simple
restriction control the squares yeah
that's why I teach my kids yeah John I
see okay see one and look see four
that's it
no seriously the business and I can't
come to before-and-after F for ya Roxy
for was a very good move
that's nice roof left Rock h4 yeah
everything that said I mean the whole
floor frame it's like controlled by and
that's it so I think Azusa for I knew
I'm gonna win the game before I wasn't
sure but I mean after Luke's before I
said that the game is over
yeah so strange that that this move
Knight d5 which is more very logical and
long castle it's logical but it's not
logical because again whenever you play
such situations you get activate your
major pieces first right yeah
and it's an end game so maybe he was
supposed to do the King in the center so
yeah so nice so let's see how how it
went after Lucy for a 5 and then 8/3
another restriction nice you think
you're taking your time and then h3 and
the restriction Wow
yeah now okay that's a it so another
blunder by the way looking for I think
it's just awful the blood yeah and then
he must give up this pawn sort of yeah
he tried to activate yeah you don't let
him yeah here he is funny like a rookie
for looking for mercy - originally I was
going to play in that c4 and win this
smooth but I thought right yesterday I I
failed his calculation so I don't know I
have to push myself to calculate rook
takes f7 and see if if I can win by
force
ok so I'm not sure if I don't know
because I don't know look yourself I
have a question so look f7 will give 7
negative 7
he took a ruby - I play g4
yeah it looks pretty good for ya I was
what about b5 move I mean HG HG I'm
surprisingly this check on v1 it does
make any sense b5 b5 and who is so voice
faster well that's why I was thinking
like it looks like a nice size so I mean
he's Lucas year so even if he plays in a
b4
well he must play before right right
yeah so here probably I have to take a B
right right
and then a fourth ok I for interesting
in a g6 well that's the petition I had
in my mind
hey three g7 a to a g8 huh
a 1 we have fun you're lying and they
found the king gage - King H - yes very
important because no checks all right
no checks and next my turn very nice and
I think I'm going to be a bunch of
checks I'm going to simply make the
black game because there's no defense on
the King so you kind of calculated this
oh yes should I feel it calculation but
this time you had more time rather you
improved in time management yeah good
job yeah so this this was pretty
convincing to me
so instead instead of taking the last
change practically that that's what he
has to do they work how well he pretty
just no chances yeah because if you try
to annoy you
there's nothing here you lost a rope
right I'm making this six that's before
them yeah yeah very nice game
congratulations and how do you feel here
and say loses it's not the first time no
no not the first time I love to come
here it's tough tough to Thomas here
yeah are you your familiy York right no
no from la la right down the coast yeah
my family and that played fewer US
Championships but never play well
because they field always I'm too old
for this but I mean when I got the
invitation from Tony I said so that's
the chance to maybe yeah reborn I don't
know yeah that's fine let's try yeah you
know you know this last week I just
turned 30 and a marathon yo-yo
but yeah the Phillies are the new
twenties right and the police on your
thirties 48 so yeah yeah so well thank
you so much for joining us and go back
in your own next round
thank you thank you guys say yes I mean
Khmer zhing show I mean I mean watching
yesterday so yeah you guys doing great
job thank you so much you know st. Louis
is honestly is the best place to play
chess
oh yeah that's why I'm come join us here
I'm living absolutely and we are going
to get into a short commercial break and
we're gonna see you after a question on
Twitter from dem s I should not have
pronounced that that was a bit of a
champion for those of you who are new to
chess it might look like ba 3 is an
illegal move here because white
announces pong two squares not one but
it still is something we call hustle and
you can do that I get to do it instantly
you can't wait for a move I gotta say
planking in seven games you too and I'll
try because this is a software glitch
and facial is
Lawrence hello Lauren yell play for
against Lawrence and now he's going to
play something against me which we
discussed at length during the course of
my steak yeah he told me this is that
fun g5 this was what I was kind of
hoping for because now I think we
finally know who Lawrence
this is not how chess works certainly
would be much much more fun if chess
actually work like this I don't think it
does well maybe it does well that's me
regretting what I just said how did I
get from there to here is a little bit
beyond me and what's worse I will never
hear the end of it my quality of life
has just gone downhill tremendously
because I'm actually sharing the office
of the guy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a weekend vacation on infinity
plus a ton welcome back to the 2018
spring chess classic I'm Ben Simon and
i'm vitaly namer and we're in the midst
of round number three you just heard
from Melek kion a former US Championship
competitor we were talking during the
break about how difficult the US
Championship has become in recent years
he played here in 2009 2011 and 2013
those were the biggest US Championships
we had here in st. Louis of course we're
coming up on the not the 10th
anniversary but the 10th edition of the
US championship here in st. Louis and
also later the summer the 10th
anniversary of the Chess Club should be
great we're gonna have Wesley so Hikaru
Nakamura
Fabiana Cara wanna the top three in the
US to be sure and then a field of really
tough contenders a 12 player tournament
here in st. Louis u.s. championship yeah
yeah we have lots of new grandmasters in
the United States and also I mean you
just mentioned Khurana and Wesley song
and from other countries but they
decided to stay here so the field
definitely getting much stronger every
year we are a country of immigrants oh
yes with the great American melting pot
as they say yeah so during the interview
we did have a game end that was in our
blacked out area of the tournament Hall
priyadarshan canna pan as white had a
draw against a wonder Leon and we have
our trooper himself Mike comer upstairs
in putting the moves if you're watching
on us chest champs calm I believe that
the entire game has been input looks
like 35 moves so that is a draw
okay so far there's there's only there
are three games left going on in Group B
Aaron grabbed its key and on Drake more
of it so it's the only one we can see
right now right grupe but all five of
the games in group a well ones already a
draw but they don't look pretty even
they tally
yeah that's let's look at some of the
games see who didn't we look at yet
what about Edward Romain and version of
Cobie an interesting point structure
looks like looks to me like maybe white
is slightly on the edge here white has a
little bit more space it's pretty equal
it's pretty accurate say the only
question is how does the black needs to
stop this de-spawn from advancing or
advancing the h-bar because if white can
create some threads like H 5 and H 4 so
we gonna weaken the King I mean just
look at the black King he's just here
alone and white can swing his row to g4
and attack one g7 so really black needs
to do something to figure out how am i
defending my most valuable piece
interesting now again probably black
black is thinking how can I exchange
pieces right because when we are under
attack
we want to exchange pieces so if black
manages to exchange Queens somehow he
can he can probably easily draw this
position yeah I feel like there's a lot
of tension in this position and this is
move 31 both players have eight minutes
and so that means they have about a
minute per move which gets them to the
time pressure
so it's gonna be interesting to see how
that game a goes by let's go to the
other one let's go to our game of the
day the zebra zone versus Alexander on
issue last time we left black had issues
with this Bishop on a8 if you remember
and to develop this row can be seven
it looks like the bishops got exchanged
so that that probably got like much much
happier although black did lose a pawn
so why does a pawn up but really those
two pawns I really don't like them
didn't happen can we go back to where we
were right so we left at somewhere
somebody here rook a7 was played now
wipe the Roku D to F one okay so I
decided to control the F file instead of
the D file okay interesting choice
maybe because if I put the roofs on the
D file were where are they going to go
the d7 square is defended the d8 who is
defended so white played roof at D to F
one in a wonder if his plan was somehow
to sacrifice the rook on f6 for the
night because that is going to pay so
for example if black would play d5 take
take rook takes and then I can swing my
queen to g5 my bishop of mine either
going to come in and really black is in
a lot of trouble so this is why the
Cuban Grandmaster played 97
now I always say that moving backwards
is not as good but in this case you have
to and I mean you have to defend unite
somehow and it's with a temple because
the knight is attacking this the Queen
on only five Wow
95 an eye for an eye doesn't work this
time though right
so let's see what happens so Queen d8 so
why did like did not take the Queen
because of the check here and King h8
what does white plant here
looks very interesting it definitely
feels like a white supposed to have
something maybe suffered some maybe
delete to capture on CA but I don't
really want to give up this night or
something on f7 I definitely have a
hunch but white should have something in
this position but this is why black
played Queen d8 again moving backwards
okay
interesting technique 24 b6 Bishop g4
there's a mate threat here on g7 so
black had to play f6 defense from the
main but also a little bit weakening the
e6 pawn Knight 2 before the threat is
Knight coming to c6 and forking the rook
and the Queen there should be seven so
finally black develops his bishop and
this is rule number 23 in the opening
principles were supposed to develop our
pieces pretty quickly
yes the knights and bishops but
sometimes sometimes we can delay the
developing of the other pieces and here
is where he sacrificed the pawn queen
a8 a nice being fun for the Queen she's
gonna be over looking over this on and
this long day I don't know although I
don't really see a use for this diagonal
right now 95 I really like this 95
relax AAPIs again I guess about knight
on e5 attacking the stroke on g4 and
this is the position that we and we have
the on camera right now Alex Andy shook
and razón both are looking at the board
calculating variations and their time is
have less than four minutes Wow they are
in move number 26 that is that is that
is gonna be a blitz now they have to
make 14 moves in four minutes yeah it's
it's it's getting down to the wire now
remember there is a 30 second increment
but it's not much in the grand scheme of
things I mean how much thinking can you
really do in 30 seconds that's really
just to make sure that you you don't run
out of time or flag as the old school my
term goes yeah so usually in these kind
of situations you just don't want to
blunder but other than that yeah it's I
think it's a very double-edged game and
every move matters so for example if
let's try this so okay well I was the
rock - I mean can I have the roof to f4
I guess I am still going back there and
now maybe room D seven D seven attacking
the Queen well in this case actually the
Queen can I'm not I don't want to hurt
to drop this pawn on d6 almost
completely well Rudi's let's try route
the eight instead get our last rope into
the game maybe Queen efore
[Music]
I'm nothing I'm pressure for me it's
even difficult to to figure out the
moves here fo for white and for black so
I think it's gonna be a very close fight
yeah it could be so though it looks like
it's equal I my bet would be that it's
not gonna be a little walk away like
friends
well we've seen it we've seen it before
that's true elsewhere in group a jeffrey
zhang and alexander panov have drawn
their game in a repetition situation
right and we left us this game somewhere
here with anything like the knight on d5
this is where we left it with after rook
c4 and I said I really like White's
night and whites position but obviously
black has has some kind of load on the F
file and the H file this Queen might
become dangerous and what like did play
b6 AHA and I cannot take the pawn
because of maybe
if I go Ruby ate that it was ambition to
be seven this person might become very
strong
so instead Jeffrey played Queen d2 there
should be six and then a five it's a
nice move now into g1 okay what was the
okay so now black wanted to take on d5
with the rook so let's see if we take on
b6 rook takes d5 pawn takes d5 and
probably Bishop takes 25 or room takes
on June 25 probably Queen takes first
take take take and we are dropping a
full piece and in this case white is
close to resigning so there are some
some problems here for white this is why
why played King g1 he was preparing for
this check Bishop takes pawn takes and
then the roof takes 25 and suddenly I
like more and more black although blacks
King is also a bit exposed on this on
this phone this diagonal check King g8
to compete 1 and our rook F 2 Wow
it is a very nice move yes so
technically white is supposed to be
better because here this passport very
dangerous passed pawn so black cannot
lose any time if you're just going to
play Ruby ate something passive then Y
can probably activities group maybe just
rookie 4 and rookie seven or maybe rook
takes a6
very very dangerous so there is no time
to waste and and Alexander found this
very accurate move
- f - obviously the first on first sight
that threat is quintics
h - checkmate so footage is a checkmate
to see so whitehead hmm so you did not
you not take the rope because if it
takes Europe it might be even pretty
dangerous basically the hunt for the
King begins in here probably going to
end in the perpetual check of some kind
I guess you couldn't mate in that
position
oh it's a very good question check it
depends it depends what the king is
going to that's a king you one check
check
so I might keep checking here
yeah so back has at least a draw or
maybe there is such a move that group to
h5 some bad crank mates might be coming
so I see how it can be dangerous for
white Eurocup are you just you're just a
tempo down
you just need one more move to to win
this game
fortunately this is why why did not take
on f2 so he played h4 instead and wrote
to d2 defending the ropes as we know the
ropes are the most powerful in the
second ranked for the seventh ranked
putting that king in a stranglehold
right there oh yeah definitely don't and
don't let him out and now that's that's
pretty much it I mean the wife has no
checks no way to defend G 2 or H 2
squares so he just took on c5 attacking
the Queen and h5 now you black tries to
move back somewhere with a queen well
now white will take the upper hand
probably will rook c8 check and then
bringing it up his queen somehow and
there's going to be some kind of a
checkmate so it's kind of a race over
here to a checkmate
so instead black and decided just to
check on g2 King H h1
and they agreed for a draw because this
rock is going to keep checking if left
tries to check with this rope let's see
if it still draw can the King escape and
the king is capable now there are no
more checks but you can check on d2 now
if I take with the Queen it's gonna
interesting well here actually that
might win in this case but the King
might get away with king c1 rotated to
queen takes it to the roof takes it to
in our rope takes it to a while so this
would be a very interesting imbalance if
this would happen in the game but I
think that really only white can win
here because of this strong form be b6
and white is gonna pick up this pawn to
a6 only why is the one who's paying for
it when so you think epitaphs decision
to force that draw was a good idea yeah
yeah plenty pretty much so this is why
he just decided to take just just to
play for a draw just repeat were there
most of these ropes good decision the
decision okay let's see what else do we
have which came to the we see on the B
team
how did Arron Korbin ski is doing
against and Andre Corbett's last time we
well I want to remind everybody watching
on us chest champs calm your eyes are
not deceiving you there are two games
that say that they're still going in
Group B and I believe that they are
however they're not on move 13 we have
lost relay to those games so in fact the
group in ski gorebyss game that we have
on the screen is the only one we have
access to in Group E right now we'll let
you know when we have updates yeah and
if people do want to see those games or
they can always come visit us in st.
Louis I mean yeah they can come and see
see it's what life there's so much to do
here in st. Louis oh yeah I mean this is
beyond the central west end you could
spend your entire trip in the central
west end where the chess campus is but
there's so much to do in st. Louis it's
just an amazing place the best
medium-sized city in the u.s.
my humble opinion yeah I had that we one
of the cities with the most free
attractions like museums and the zoo is
completely free I mean you can donate if
you want but in Forest Park and the zoo
there's nothing like it I used to live
within walking distance of it I said how
cool is it that I can walk to the zoo
and see sea lions oh that's amazing
yeah probably hear them at night and
just that much I live in the park yeah
it's very exciting city yeah with it
with the arch lots of things to do here
great food by the way barbecue right we
have great barbecue meat create
everything toasted ravioli have you had
that yet oh of course
okay so we left here in this position so
as you can see the players both made
move number folding let me refresh the
page and let's see what is going on here
there were a few exchanges let's see so
black so white is still white is a pond
down now and I really don't like that
King on h1 aligned
with the Queen Utz on c6 really don't
like that I mean that that is gonna open
up at some point I am yes what is
attacking this night on the floor but I
wonder if I'm really thinking do I
really need to move this night or do I
have some other tactical chances here
and if I do move this night well the
night can either go to d3 attacking the
stroke on a1 and locking this defense of
the Queen on e4 so this is one option
and that can also jump to e to attack
the roof from here and that can go to h5
even though I like this a bit less but
he's gonna put his eye on this pawn g3
lots and lots of options and Fisker
Pinsky have any options here let me I
know it's black smooth but yeah that is
a good question well technically
well if let's say if we make some some
passive move with this night I would see
that first of all there is this isolated
pawn on c5 maybe we can try to move our
roof to c1 or maybe even playing
something like b4 after before basically
the pawn is pinned so you can't take it
also moving the King to h2 will be
pretty interesting because I move my
queen away from that pin and the king is
going to take that pollen h3 and again I
don't think that blacks King is exposed
I mean obviously this diagonal a to g8
might become an issue for black but
right now here's the rock on d5 so yeah
I it's hard to find some some kind of
play without without the feeling for for
my King's life on here he has some
chances definitely
definitely yes let's see if we have any
other games in the a way of not
discussed I think so much sure booking
ganguly yet not sure that we've looked
at that right group a so we looked at I
think this is this was the game we left
that there was a queen on a six if I'm
not if I'm not mistaken let's see well
did we leave it it was somebody here
this is what we left it away said okay
one but I'm not sure the Queen on a six
how is she doing over there
rook b8 King the six king be won and
rook Bishop to see it was played Queen a
three take and take and Bishop e6 going
back and forth so black has the two
bishops but White has a material
advantage but I don't now well when
White's pawn structure is damaged it's
very unclear I have to say not even sure
who would be playing for win in such a
position because so they double edged
very double-edged so let's see what
happened Bishop a5 white did exchange
Bishop after all g3 pawn takes Bishop f6
rookie 3d 5 ok well I really like those
2 points now they don't look so
dangerous right now
but trust me those those guys are moving
forward and once they get to somewhere
to the 3rd rank
White's gonna feel the pressure
also if the black is not playing d4 and
puttin on only 3
it's what the cut the rooks away from
from defending this a trip on and I
think that white might get into trouble
so let's see what having a king D 1 e 4
was played very good age for why he's
trying to get some kind of play King f5
Age 5 I wonder why he didn't take this
pawn on h4
so you take rook takes on g7 my white
might get some counter play by by
checking the king from from the sides so
maybe this is why so work just prefer to
play with the king h5 king f4 for the
King I mean this this King is that is
the power of the King over there the
king is basically working the two rooks
not allowing them to move backwards or
forward wanting and chasing those two
pretty much like handcuffing those two
rooks so this is why the yellow play the
groove to beat three and now we have our
last move that was played was D for I
yeah I don't think that white has a very
good chances here although his material
output those pawns are moving and I
don't see why how can I stop them
yeah you wouldn't really think it's an
if you were just looking at material
that Y would be in a tough situation
like this but he those rooks are really
restricted right now exactly and don't
forget it because I had to see for a c6
pony that might jump in at some point
and yeah yeah so it's gonna be
intersecting it's gonna be a long a long
game especially for y'all to think but
how do I find other I'll save myself I
would suspect that he is thinking about
King to eat to hear about the wait a
second Kenny breaking it to if your
place came to like has this amazing move
d3 check and that's it why cause I know
why because there isn't the connection
between the ropes is being cut and now
if it takes the pawn then the king
so GJ so you already see that we even
have some tactics in the endgame it's
getting dangerous so the King cannot
come to three to Kim D - maybe but you
know the problem is such positions is
that just white is just paralyzed black
has no weaknesses I mean g7 is not ideal
witness CC it might be some kind of a
weakness but there's no way to attack it
and yeah I mean that can back even if
playing just moves is his rook Beck was
a forward I mean there is no way that
they can lose this that would be
impossible so yeah tough tough spot for
Yarra tough spot so we are going to get
back to this game alright and in Group B
been told that international master
Jackson and bully AK has well his game
has ended with Grandmaster Michalowski
we do not know the result as of yet that
is one of the boards that we had the
disconnection on but that game is over
we'll find out shortly who won or if it
was a draw yeah just just to show a
little quick what they they have in the
opening
so check stem buddhic is playing white
pieces against Victor Michalowski
and we have the groennfell defense in
that defense wide is giving a black is
giving up the center just in order for
for black to attack the center and it
sounds some strange like I said I'm
giving you the center please take it but
then it's coming coming over there with
the bishops and the pawn say usually
they're the main move here is something
like Knight to f3 that's the main oh but
I think Jack surprised Victor with
between a 4 I'm sure the Jack the pellet
in at home because I know that Victor is
playing the role for many times and that
that's how it goes in professional chess
you gotta prepare for your opponent not
a day before but sometimes even two
weeks before so there's a long time
before sire
I'm sure that this all was prepared and
I really liked if you can see this
position white is delaying his castle
he's not cancelling yet but he just
wants to take out all these pieces out I
really like white white center because
usually black needs to play this move c5
to undermine the center somehow but
really right now the the 1916 the bishop
on g7 although they are attacking this
pawn on d4 but that's been a much it so
let's see what having Bishop g4 27 and
this is pretty much where we got cut and
I really like the whites position so I
wonder if if Jack was able to to win
this game to use the his advantage
well the whole house do we have
in the 80 I think that we have okay what
about this game and drug domain versus a
very generic Obon Rahman and a copy an
endgame here look at that
now if if our video commentating would
go for all the game me and you would
stay here for the whole night I think
yes I mean look at this this is this is
one of those you know this is gonna be
like what they call it just grinding
black is definitely going to try to use
this pawn and white is going to you know
to defend ferociously I don't know even
what what the TV says it I mean
definitely black and some chances to win
here now the way black needs to win here
to try to win is obviously to somehow to
create a passport from this easy
exponent but this is a long way to go
because it is super e 5/5 movie screen
push the pawns folder and on the other
hand white will try to do some kind of a
perpetual check so if the let's say a
black right now it so it's black double
the queen is attacking the epsilonpu
let's say that will play a five white
can play something like Queen f7 if I
and then maybe H five then the idea is
that now if let's say black is just
moving a squid away the idea for white
is just to check on g6
and queen to to e8 that's just an
example for example so obviously he can
also take on e5 but yes so this is
White's plan this is how he is going to
defend to try to create a perpetual
check and yeah hopefully hopefully they
got lots of sleep today because they are
up for a fight I would say at least and
I won't and I only have maybe every two
hours usually such games I mean they
move number 42 you I would I would say
to go to move a hundred they probably
gonna break another moves it could
happen again in the odds you you think
will have a 100 move game in this
tournament I was just about to say the
odds of getting one but what do you
think I I would bet that this is this is
gonna be the game yeah yeah we'll
probably have a 100 move game this
tournament this might be it yeah I mean
just think about it I mean there
everybody is paying for this big problem
my money prize they traveled all the way
from from world a that live to st. Louis
or Kobe and didn't have to come far
right the papaya ten miles exactly he
just sees just to see or on the other
side of the street but but yeah well by
the way he is playing the black piece of
saw wonder the fact that he lives in st.
Louis might benefit him you know it's
like the the whole field right for this
home-field advantage
yes that might put the confidence into
it exactly so that is going to be an
interesting missing game to follow where
else do we have
[Music]
I really want to look at fear versus
Chandra but we can't I keep looking back
to that and then remembering darn we've
lost the feet for that game but it means
as far as I go I think that's the game
of the day and Group B there's a lot on
the line with fear and Chandra but they
are playing in the dark so to speak
right now as far as their game getting
out to the world
yeah we can the only thing we can do is
we can look at the opening what happened
there or so d4 Knight of 64 so we have
the nimzo-indian defense one of the most
popular defenses for black against the
first move D fallen c4 III very
fashionable today Castle Bishop d2 the
other move him for white white Sanders
plays Knight f3 white also sometimes
tries to put the knight on g - e - it's
kind of a strange move but to defend a
knight on c3 but chose Bishop d3 c5 this
is pretty much all theory and d5 castle
with a bunch of exchanges and now b6 I
know that I have played a few of those
games myself I usually take on d4 first
and then usually white
well if white takes with the night and
we have a very symmetrical pawn
structure and it's just a very even I
mean there's just no place of that b6
and Bishop b2 and 96
super super even so usually after the
context on default white tries to take
on default with a pawn and no that's
that's the question of all questions is
this point good and deforest it's an
isolated pawn so technically it's not
supposed to be so good but on the other
hand the white gets lots of space
advantage and there are lots of options
for him to play d5 and move forward so
so this has been interesting but I
played b6 and now why did get the two
bishop advantage in 97 I would say that
this position overall it's pretty pretty
equal again white has the two bishop
advantage and probably black would put
his roofs on d8 and c8 on those two
files and why could try to push this
pawn to e4 kind of reminds us the
groennfell but not not executive is not
Bishop Heelan g7 and yeah so yeah it's
so far I would say this is equal but
we'll see what happens people are we
gonna be kept surprised what else do we
have right now well let's uh let's pause
for just a moment and catch everybody up
to date here in the midst of round
number three in Group A we do have two
games that have finished both of them
were draws three games are in progress
let's take a look at the standings right
now I mean we'll get as much as we can
out of them three games still pending of
course yeah so let's see so we still
have Geoffrey Zhang with two points on
the top Alexander and you should
initiate as a point and a half together
with Sam chenkin and dahlias village but
Alexander only shook is still playing
and as a remember we said that he
had a really good good position right
now it looks like he's probably going to
draw and if he will draw then even Jeff
they're gonna go head to head
now they have not played yet
Jeffrey and Alexandra on issue and I
wonder if they at what run though they
gonna play because if they are going to
play and in the end that's gonna be
pretty exciting yeah hopefully that
would be a I'll pull it up here and
we'll know in just a moment
in the interim how about Group B do we
have Group A standings we the the day
that the dgt died I'll tell you what two
games have finished and three are still
in progress we have access to one right
now we grab in ski and gore vets but
yeah we're gonna see if action Chandra
that's the that's the result I want to
see Chandra and fear that's gonna tell
us a lot about how this tournament could
could turn out yeah yeah definitely so
if action will draw or win he will still
still be on the top lots of lots of
things are still playing
okay so we were looking at what round do
owner shook and Jean play each other
yeah so if they pay in the end it's
going to be exciting because so far that
their leading round nine round nine a
very last row oh wow yeah I can't get
better than that
yeah everybody's performance holds even
as little bit of an edge as it is yeah
that will be a de facto final and when
you can get one of those in a round
robin event that's special because round
robins sometimes i mean you have to say
it is anti-climatic sometimes yeah you
might have the ultimate winner
determined by a game that doesn't have
the winner in it in the last round so oh
it's going to be playing white that is a
good question it looks like Zhang will
have black okay I'm sorry it looks like
Zhang will have white
well it's 50/50 whatever yeah I think I
read that wrong in the first date this
thing yeah so we're gonna have the the
yang master
against the experience master yeah you
don't want to call them old because you
might beat up on that it's not because
I'm overseas Asia that means if I'm
gonna be calling myself alright game if
this all holds how it is well we have
about a 10 minutes till typically we
would sign off the air I wish we could
get more answers to these questions
before we did so though about these
games yeah so we can still look at the
few of the games give it a few minutes
let's see let's jump to Corvettes and on
Aaron Grove in ski he did Android did
move his Knight to e5 and
as predicted but he spent a lot of time
on that move and I wonder why still the
Aaron is is Elias is always ahead of
time which is good I guess but the
position is not so easy yeah this Knight
here is pinned not so easy for white to
make any moves yeah as I mentioned it
white wants to play king h2 but that
that would not be possible because of
1934 so and that's support this is a
form yes you guys have a show don't go
oh man what a segue that was yes why we
do don't get for it that's a special
guest once upon a time actually did you
solve the fort I got it right yeah yeah
then you get a fork in it i got a fork
yes very nice what happens if you if you
do it wrong you get like stabbed with a
fork oh you get a spoon yes thank you
for reminding me yeah well most people
most people get it right you know and if
they don't get it right then we can walk
through the answer and find out how you
don't get forward you don't want to get
forward exactly I just don't get for it
subscribe to our YouTube channel STL
chess club you're watching this
broadcast there anyway so why not click
that button us chess champs calm is
where you want to be to see these games
this is just always stuff going around
on around here at the Chess Club be it
on YouTube or us chess champs it's all
awesome oh yeah definitely and by the
way I as again master resident here the
same place chess club I have lots of
lectures that they give lots of private
lessons so if you could if anybody's
interested they can just come in here
but and to make it easier for the
viewers at home and we post those videos
online yes of the lectures we have over
1,500 videos it includes not only the
chess broadcast but many more videos of
all the lectures and in fact vitality
and
couple of weeks you have a very special
lecture coming up that all the people
here in st. Louis will get to see first
but it'll be posted online I'm talking
about alpha zero yeah definitely one of
my most exciting lectures is about about
the match of alpha zero and stock fish
which was just recently happened and we
did get lots of coverage and but I want
to really emphasize how important that
was I mean that was a pretty magnificent
match and thing you are going to see
alpha zero come back and try try again
to win again and yes I just want to
explain a few few tactics a few
maneuvers lots of the people they don't
in the end understand how maybe affected
us but I think that the computers in
Osprey have to walk together especially
in chess population everybody today
pretty much uses chess engines so yeah
it's it's a very exciting moment and I
would be very glad to give that veteran
you sound a little more diplomatic than
Grandmaster Danish Boros did when he
talked about alpha zero on her YouTube
channel he wasn't so complimentary I
suspect maybe your opinions differ but
we'll have to hear yeah yeah I'm Pro
technology let's bring it on I like it
okay so what do you think Natalia we've
I mean in group in ski and gaurav it's
the group a game yeah I would I would
put my money on Andre corabeth's and it
looks like he's keeping his momentum he
won yesterday if he if he wins today
with black and then tomorrow he's gonna
be very coming to the game very
confident playing the white pieces after
winning two games and yeah so I will put
this game as the probably black will
probably win this game we don't know
what
victim AHA laughs kids still they are
still playing know that game that game
is over we just don't know the result is
that the case hmm yeah we don't know the
result if the game has ended well
luckily you know it's a round-robin so
even if you don't know the result we
still know the pairings for the next
round right yes it's not like a Suisse
that if you don't know the result you
know he can't make the pairings but
that's true yeah and that also factors
into a lot of the players preparation
you know we were talking about Melek
earlier in the preparation and because
it is a round-robin you know who you're
gonna play so there's no surprises not a
big Swiss tournament where the pairings
go round around get a lot of surprises
that way you're not so much yeah I mean
they're pairs no no who are they playing
yes even what color they're playing
against them so it gives them lots and
lots of time I know that from my
experience I usually start to prepare
immediately pretty much even two weeks
before the game it is not the same in
just an open Swiss and I know there have
been to a few chess tournaments here in
the United States and some of them don't
even give you any any time to prepare
they they even specifically publish the
pairings just 10 minutes before the
round and I remember that I used to go
to mine to play against my opponent some
opponents they really they actually
deliberately will be late to the game
for 20 minutes maybe maybe half an hour
just because they really want that time
to prepare for their opponent so vacuum
yeah we don't have those those problems
here no we don't now if you're watching
this broadcast on the chest 24 module
you will not see the pairings for the
next round they just aren't loaded in
yet but they exist so if you want to see
the games that will be played tomorrow
you can on us chess champs calm under
spring chess classic at the top go to
pairings and results and they are in
there they don't look as pretty as chess
24 but they are there and you will
see that tomorrow we have games like a
wonder young and Melek cacci on Chandra
vs. priyadarshan this is groupie by the
way of course her Pinsky alexander fear
JJ a lemur on D versus Jackson bully AK
and Andre Gore vets versus Victor
mikhalev ski and in Group A daro spirits
versus Alexander eepa table Ganguly vs.
Zhang Bru zone versus ash Arabic Akopian
and ona shook that should be a good one
in Shanklin vs. Edouard so that's all
coming your way tomorrow yeah very
exciting stuff and by the way on the
same website and people can can read the
bio
of the players yes we do have the bios
for all the players some of these names
you may not have heard before and some
of you want to get reacquainted with so
the bios are all available at us chest
champs calm I think we'll probably have
some photos from our club photographer
Austin fuller available as well well
that might do it
eyetality I know it's it's 5 o'clock we
work in 9 to 5 shift it's very very
strict so but you can keep watching the
games at us chest champs calm remember
each day the round itself starts at 1:00
p.m. Central time we come on the air at
3:30 p.m. with the exception of the last
couple of rounds so us chess champs calm
is the place to be and this broadcast
was produced by the world's greatest
production B team Tammy Hyde is the
technical advisor Jonathan Krantz was
getting interviews Isaac Krantz is on
graphics and sound our technical
director is Danny Machuca my name is Ben
Simon and I have Italian aimer and until
tomorrow at 3:30 p.m. we say so long
from the Show Me State
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you
you